it's like the best concept of it like
like a like reality tv program that
you've seen
like physical like game show challenge
anything like ninja warrior
the original the japanese original
sasuke yeah yeah that's really good
there's this really old reality tv show
that channel 4 made
um i can't remember the name because it
was like a one-off series right but i
always remember it because
i thought the concept was genius because
what they did
is this was this was way back when when
big brother was like a massive
thing um but the twist was they took
they took these
group of people right um that uh
weren't exactly the brightest brightest
bunch of people but you know wanted to
be on a reality tv show
and they would basically they basically
convinced them that they were going to
go to space
right oh i think i remember this so what
so what happens is they they literally
go
they literally like take them astronaut
training right
and make them go through all the
training but also feed them like a bit
of fake information right
because they had they had this real mock
spaceship
um and they taught them that you know we
we are using new technology where it
doesn't require rockets it's kind of
like an
airplane where like slowly circles up to
the earth's atmosphere
and these guys would believe it right
and they thought they thought they were
like being trained in russia
what's the name of the show i can't
remember i'm gonna have to look it up
because
it was a genius show um and like at any
point if like at any point one of them
could have found out right because they
were
they were um the t the producers said
you know you're gonna be trained in
russia
it's not gonna be in england and what
happened is they just took them on a
plane and just like
circled round and just landed in a
landed in like a
abandoned airfield in surrey or
something like that so they were just
like in the middle of england i think
they were thinking they were going to
space
and they actually took some of these
people and just uh
have you ever been on like one of those
fake rollercoaster rides where
where where it's like it's kind of like
like the 4d ones yeah like the 4d ones
where where you know you just
you just you just kind of like have this
spaceship that just kind of turns
out it's cool yeah it's called space
cadets
yeah it aired in 2005 on channel 4. yeah
yeah channel 4 normally does all the
really bizarre really unique game shows
yeah okay if
if if you got like if you got some time
you want to kill that's honestly
it was such a good concept and it was a
one-off as well one-off season um
it was just hilarious it was [ __ ]
hilarious highly recommend it
yeah the first thing that comes up when
you google it is like controversies
that's been quite controversial i guess
so i want to watch that now
yeah sounds really funny yeah that was
like this the uk has some really
unique game shows yeah the haunted one
right
there was cool basically there's a game
show in the uk um i think it was
literally called hunted
and they would have like i think six
pairs or
ten pairs something around that and
basically what they would do is
they were like all right you have like
one day and then we're going to start
trying to
like track you as if you're a fugitive
all right so like any of your
if you use your phone if you use your
phone if you do anything you make calls
you go to places like they'll find you
right and so some people were really
good at it and some people were terrible
at it and like yeah and then they had to
survive
two weeks yeah two weeks later two weeks
and then go to a
location to get like a plane to like to
escape
right right and uh yeah what one one
team did win
that sounds really fun it was really
cool it was really it was really popular
the first season then the second season
i think was a bit [ __ ] yeah and
didn't do too well yeah
i feel that's a concept like at first
that would be like wow that's cool but
then i feel it'll get
old quite fast yeah because there's so
much there's only so much you can do
once you know the formula and what you
know the secrets
like just something like the the
logistics uh behind that must have been
like
crazy yeah like i wonder how much of
that was faked though as well because
you surely can't have access to all the
like
the police forces like yeah credibility
right because it's just a waste of
police time and services right that's
just a lot of government
there's anything because youtube hold on
wait we gotta find the fake one what i
mean
i wonder but in a concept really cool
yeah yeah
was that on channel four as well that
was on channel four as well channel four
makes some good like one-off reality i'm
surprised i've never heard of any of
these
yeah channel 4 makes really good tv
shows in general